a group of unemployment claimants are
worried about not getting paid this is
because their claims are under review
after filing their weekly claims
joe muller live at dieter with more on
what exactly people are experiencing joe
well brian claiman's filed their weekly
claims every weekend and when someone to
file yesterday
they say that response that they got
after they filed their claim was a
little odd and now they don't know what
exactly to do next
typically it says uh you you
will be paid this week bethlehem celsius
says this window popped up when she went
to file
the response was different this time
around and it said that my
claim was still under review it is a
window that many received more than
usual says amber hansen who runs a
popular facebook help group
we're seeing a few things that are
happening we know that there are some
people that are
exhausted and they haven't fully
implemented the remaining
seven weeks those people hansen is
describing are the handful of people who
are waiting for the extension to kick
in something dieter is working on the
window that many are getting
is this it says your claim is still
under review
why they are getting it is not clear and
typically we see those
types of things like during quarter
changes and so it was just kind of very
odd that over this weekend we had seen
an enormous
increase in people getting that screen
meanwhile hanson says these folks will
be without payments until this is
figured out
something else that is new and not known
if it is related
is different questions asking claimants
how they are impacted by coven 19.
i think what's happening is that
obviously there have been new dol
guidelines
obviously you know the cares act had had
some additional
legislation and language and
bipartisanship language that was added
to it
so she says the only thing different
this week has been different answers to
those virus questions
previously i was answering that it was
due to a reduction of freelance work
um they removed that option uh changed
the wording a little bit and i selected
the very last option which was the
the closest to my previous answer
now we did submit some questions to
dieter in regards to those questions
about the virus to see if that has any
sort of
relation to this issue that people are
having we have yet to hear back as soon
as we learn more
we'll be sure to pass it on reporting
live here at the dealer office joe
mullen 8 news now